ouverte première diffusion d'émissions
manifestent les radios verte haute
arrivée hier sur paris
bravant la loi ouvertement puisqu'on
leur avait refusé leur demande de
dérogation au monopole
elles sont arrivées par provocation pour
rompre les carcans de la non
communication pour protester contre la
mainmise sur la france du monopole
d'état
les émetteurs sont assemblés à partir de
pièces détachées pour ensuite régler ces
pièces détachées une fois qu'elles sont
assemblés il faut un certain nombre
d'appareils comme un fréquencemètre un
contrôleur universel un oscilloscope qui
nous permettent de savoir que les
émetteurs sont propres qui ne bave pas
sur d'autres fréquences et qui
n'entraîne pas de gêne pour les autres
usagers car ces autres usagers pour être
facilement gêner ce sont les ambulances
les avions la police qui ne faut
évidemment pas gêné pour pas de ne
donner de prétexte donc les émetteurs
fonctionne parfaitement bien
on avait certains à partir de ces
mesures et ces mesures peuvent être
doublée à partir d'un autre système de
mesure dans des laboratoires
professionnels dont nous avons la
complicité avec leurs émetteurs fourmis
cachés dans des appartements leurs
émissions de courte durée très localisés
les radios écologistes comptent bien
jouer longtemps les services de
détection du ministère de l'intérieur
était ptt forget n'évitons par toute
cette histoire
vous at on demandé d'être
particulièrement vigilants en ce moment
je ne peux pas répondre particulièrement
la solution la plus simple consiste à
acheter dans le commerce un émetteur
modulation de fréquence auquel on
rajoute un ampli qui vous permet de
couvrir tout paris en émission sans
aucun problème monsieur voisin
interviewé au jardin des plantes est
venu travailler lui-même son émission
faire parler faire participer contre l'
isolement dans les villes à paris dans
chaque quartier des groupes écologistes
se sont créés ils veulent constituer une
hydre à mille têtes apparaissent en
tantôt l'un tantôt ailleurs je pense que
ça va changer ce sont eux pas toujours
les mêmes qui vont parler des mêmes
et puis je vais peut-être enfin savoir
ce qui se passe dans cette ville
réellement nous avons rencontré d'autres
quartiers peut apporter quoi que ce soit
quelqu'un de perpignan rien sa part vous
vend du quartier dans les quartiers
c'est comme on y vit moi nous prenons
radio dans ma rue j'ai quand même
remercier tous les jours où va ce qui
s'y passe c'est pas la peine d'avoir une
réunion de quartier ça ne signifie rien
c'est complètement imbécile c'est là
l'aberration démocratique ce ford ou par
tout le monde va parler normalement on
parle et c'est un art le boîtier rattle
survenus ce qu'ils réclament
vous avez d'autres questions non pour
l'instant ni de savoir si ce serait une
radio écologie sous une trappe à noyers
de réclamer de lait cil qui est le poilu
ce que nous ne voulons pas c'est que une
dérogation monopole permettra au groupe
amaury à monsieur bleustein-blanchet à
tous ceux qui tapis dans l'ombre
n'attendent que ça pour se dire ça va
nous permettre d'augmenter à la fois nos
bénéfices est également nos moyenne
puissance
du côté de la majorité les décrets
d'application de la loi de 1972 doivent
être soumis au conseil d'état dans les
semaines qui viennent
le pc le ps compte aborder précisément
un problème du monopole dans le
programme commun réactualisé on parle de
radio verte et gouvernement guy groux
mais attention attention
qu'est-ce qui veut faire de la
répression comme dans tous les domaines
mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'il régule
la vraie solution chez un grand débat
national sur la démocratie des ondes et
des images dans le cadre du service
public et d'une manière adjacentes la
démocratie comment dirais-je d'aidé
l'utilisation des nouvelles techniques
et partout avec une dominante le
pluralisme le pluralisme le pluralisme
tout est prêt techniquement pour que les
émissions aient lieu les autorités
peuvent évidemment décider où vient de
nous brouiller ou même de nous arrêter
dans ces cas là nous faisons évidemment
pas le poids mais pour plein de raisons
il n'est pas sûr qu'il le fasse